los trenes vuelven a funcionar
conectando china continental con Hong
Kong durante la política china de cero
covid la frontera quedó sellada esta
hongkonesa lleva tres años sin ver a su
madre un emotivo reencuentro está a la
vuelta de la esquina
pasaron mucho tiempo desde 2020 enero ha
sido muy duro este tiempo
decenas de miles de familias han estado
esperando este momento
les he echado mucho de menos Estoy muy
contenta
en el centro de Hong Kong los
preparativos para el año nuevo lunar
están muy avanzados es la primera
festividad sin restricciones sanitarias
desde el inicio de la pandemia pero
algunos residentes temen el regreso de
la gente de China continental cuando me
enteré de la reapertura me escribí para
vacunarme pero tuve que hacer fila
durante dos o tres semanas para
conseguir una cita
me preocupa que haya otro brote Así que
necesito más dosis
A diferencia de lo que ocurre en el
Continente aquí en Hong Kong hay vacunas
de ARN disponibles esta mujer de unos 60
años se ha vacunado tres veces en su
país Pero ha viajado 1500 kilómetros
para recibir una vacuna concreta
Esta es la vacuna de pfizer funciona
contra la cepa original y omicron
es gratuita para los residentes de Hong
Kong para Los visitantes cuesta 220
euros
se dice que esta vacuna es más eficaz
decenas de clínicas privadas acogen a
pacientes que vienen del continente
hay mucho interés de los del continente
por venir hay mucha demanda miles
predecimos que habrá un aumento a
finales de marzo o abril
a medida que aumentan los casos de covid
19 en China las autoridades de Hong Kong
han limitado el número de visitantes de
las regiones administrativa especial
Sólo se permite cruzar la frontera a
60.000 personas al día